hi
hi this you right yeah that's
me are you the actor Andy
Samberg I am you are are you kidding I'm
a big fan man like a big fan oh thank
you very much hey I got a question for
you do you like limos do I like limos
sure yeah who doesn't right
right you want to get
in
uh sure yeah come
[Music]
on congrats you've been selected
thanks for
what um I don't know
so um you know what I'm not memorized so
I'm just gonna read this off the card
are you the contract to me or h no sorry
you're good don't okay yeah uh Thomas
Walcott single no children no dependence
job is Network management focusing on
statistical analysis physically
fit enough guess they're not too strict
about that one I'm joking kind of
serious though all right I'll keep it
going here I'm sorry I'll keep it going
I'm going to keep it tight uh after your
breakup you move back in with your
mother sry Andy samre how do you know
all this oh the company that hired me I
think they've been tracking you for a
while there's a company that's been
tracking me I guess what I would say is
don't ask me any specific questions
because they told me nothing I I don't
know any details about what it is but I
do need to ask you do you want to
continue on this
adventure
um it yes
really really yeah definitely why would
you say yes cuz this is the most
exciting thing that's happened to me in
ages and I don't want it to end okay I
mean if I say if I say no then I have to
go back to my life and my life is in
this routine it's like I'm stuck so
saying yes has to be better than that
right I mean no not necessarily but man
the way you just phrase that so sad um
all right let's
go
[Music]
how long until we get to uh the next
spot of the
adventure
supp how
come I think they're just they want to
use all of this build up the
tension
[Music]
okay you see that red door walk through
it there will be small red arrows on the
ground end walls just follow those
you're not coming oh no I'm done yeah
they just paid me to get you here
so well it was really awesome to meet
you
yeah maybe we could get a beer good luck
man
yeah thank you
[Music]
yeah
e
[Music]